well this is a very interesting thing
and this is based on in some way
introspection of my own thinking about
the character of my own memories but
this idea of low sigh and place that
goes way back it goes it's certainly
Cicero had this notion that in order to
remember things they have to be placed
and there's a you know memory systems
would often use a house say you need to
memorize a speech and what the technique
would mean was that you would give
yourself a spatial location usually a
house you would walk through it as you
give the speech so you would assign
various parts of the speech to different
rooms and this seems to help keep the
words inside you I have found that all
of my memories seem to need a place and
that a good part of what we think of as
explicit memory is has to do with
location so for example it is not that
when you started going to grade school
so you went to the same school that you
remember every day of your grade school
experience what you are remembering is
the site of those experiences some of
them explicit and many of them
completely buried or forgotten I find
that I need to locate my memories there
was one illustration that I gave in the
book that interested me it was a failure
of my own memory and error and this is
what it was when I was 4 years old I was
in Norway with my mother and sister we
were at my aunt's house sitting around
the table having a meal I remember I I
can see the living room perfectly in my
mind one my cousin my older cousin V
Beckett begins to cry
I love
this cousin she was older than then
she's still older than I am and so I
felt bad I didn't know why she was
crying I pushed myself off the chair and
I remember you know I my feet were
dangling so I had to draw went around
and patted my cousin on her arm to
comfort her and all the grown-ups burst
into laughter and I was so angry and
humiliated by that laughter of course no
one meant any harm but I was for only a
few years ago I've carried this memory
of humiliation around with me my whole
life only a couple of years ago I
recognized that it couldn't have taken
place in that living room because that
house had not been built what had
happened was that in order to preserve
the memory I replaced one house with
another another my aunts second house
the one built after that I do remember
vividly I think this tells us something
about the nature of memory first of all
that it's shifting there are no fixed
original memories that we can actually
get ahold of and that place is somehow
vital to the retention of those memories
even if we need an artificial house to
put it in